good morning Hank it's Tuesday let's
talk about the health care proposals of
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton but
first I should say that if you're
interested in health care or health in
general you should check out healthcare
triage hosted by dr. Aaron Carroll it's
an amazing show okay to understand the
candidates proposals we need to look at
the current health care system and its
problems so journey back with me to 2008
at the time most Americans got insurance
through private companies there was a
publicly funded program for the elderly
to get insurance called Medicare many
low-income families got coverage through
a publicly funded program called
Medicaid and about 15% of Americans had
no health insurance at all so broadly
speaking back in 2008 our health care
system had three huge problems the first
was those 15% of people without
insurance many people who didn't work
for big companies including me literally
could not get health insurance for any
price because private insurers could
deny you based on pre-existing
conditions and for many other people
private insurance plans were just too
expensive to afford and that brings me
to our second big problem back in 2008
which was that our health care just cost
too much we were spending 16 percent of
our nation's total economic output on
health care most other rich nations
spend under 10 percent like our health
care costs were so stupefyingly high
that in the United States more tax
dollars per capita went to health care
spending than Germany Japan the United
Kingdom or Canada all those countries
spending fewer tax dollars per person on
health care had universal publicly
funded health care the United States had
nothing close to that also lastly for
all this money we were spending not to
insure everyone we weren't getting
particularly good health care outcomes
liked by almost any measure from life
expectancy to medical errors to hospital
admissions for preventable diseases the
United States was not near at the top so
then comes the affordable care act of
2009 which was designed to address some
of these problems with the emphasis on
the some the ACA was primarily designed
to get more people health insurance
about half of the newly insured were
supposed to get Medicaid which was
expanded to include everyone making up
to 138 percent of the poverty line and
the other half were supposed to get
insurance through exchanges these
marketplaces where everyone can get
health insurance regardless of
pre-existing conditions and the
insurance would be affordable because
households making up to 400% of the
poverty line would have their insurance
cost subsidized by the government on
these exchanges see ACA also sought to
reduce spending by lowering costs
in Medicare and it raised some new taxes
including one on medical devices so that
the rest of the US healthcare system
largely unchanged so that was the basic
idea now the ACA has never been fully
implemented because a 2012 Supreme Court
decision made the Medicaid expansion
optional for states and nineteen states
have so far declined to do it which
means the millions of poor Americans
remain uninsured that said the ACA has
been successful at reducing the number
of uninsured people today it's around
nine point one percent and it may have
played a role although experts disagree
about this in the slowing growth of
health care costs in the United States
for the 20 years before 2008 health care
costs in the United States rose by an
average of 8 percent in the last five
years they've risen by an average of
five point five percent but to be clear
costs are still rising faster than
inflation and median weekly earnings
health care outcomes continue to lag
behind and our health care system is
still far far more expensive than any
other nation on earth although the gap
with Europe has closed a bit the ACA
wasn't really designed to address those
problems and it hasn't and there are
other problems too and the employer
market premiums and deductibles are
rising as employers cover on average a
smaller percentage of health care
expenses than they did 10 years ago
on the exchanges some insurance
companies are offering fewer plans and
because insurers are now required to
offer comprehensive coverage with no
lifetime benefit limits many people who
previously had bare-bones insurance
plans have seen their insurance costs go
way up these are all real problems but
it's very important to understand that
the structural shortcomings of the
United States healthcare system are much
much older than Obamacare the ACA is not
the reason our health care costs are so
high and we know that because they were
very high before the ACA so with all
that in mind let's look at both
candidates health care reform proposals
using analysis from the RAND Corporation
which is nonpartisan and widely
considered centrist let's start with
Trump's plan first he would repeal the
ACA now Trump is said he'll find ways to
make sure that private insurers continue
offering plans to people with
pre-existing conditions but he hasn't
said how this would be possible Trump
had also changed the way Medicaid is
funded to block grants this would
basically mean that states get to
administer their own Medicaid programs
but most analyses see these block grants
over time involving lots of cuts and
lastly Trump would allow insurance
companies to sell plans across state
lines and he would also make all hell
insurance premiums tax deductible but
remember these are deductions not tax
credits so they would mostly benefit
people with high incomes for reasons
explained in this video all together the
rand analysis concludes and I'm just
going to quote here the Trump proposals
decreased the number of insured increase
out-of-pocket spending for consumers
enrolled in individual market plans and
raise the federal deficit compared to
the ACA so here's how around nineteen
point seven million people would lose
their insurance if the ACA were repealed
and Medicaid Block Grants would probably
increase the number of uninsured further
sales of plans across state lines and
tax deductible premiums would get some
people insured but all in all Rand
concludes that about twenty point three
million fewer Americans would have
health insurance under Trump's plan
out-of-pocket expenses would go up
according to Rand for two reasons first
because the tax deductions offered by
the Trump plan are less generous than
the tax credits offered by the ACA and
secondly they estimate that sales of
plans across state lines would raise
out-of-pocket expenses because there
would be an increase in the so-called
bare-bones plans these are plans with
high co-pays or deductibles or limits to
annual or lifetime benefits Rand
estimates that the average annual
out-of-pocket expenses per person
including deductibles and co-pays and
insurance premiums and everything would
go from about $3,200 per person to fifty
seven hundred dollars per person and the
deficit would go up because with the
repeal of the ACA the taxes it raised
would also be repealed as with the
changes in Medicare reimbursement this
would go or some taxes but most of the
savings were in changes to Medicare so
all in all under Trump's plan according
to RAM the deficit would go up by about
5.8 billion dollars and I should add
that all the nonpartisan analyses I
could find agreed on all three fronts
the Trump's plan would reduce the number
of insured people increase out-of-pocket
costs and increase the deficit okay
let's move on to Hillary Clinton's
proposals Clinton would amend the ACA
and three big ways first she would
introduce a $2,500 tax credit or $5,000
for married couples filing jointly that
could be applied to health care expenses
over five percent of income so if you're
a single person making fifty thousand
dollars a year and you pay five thousand
dollars a year in health insurance
premiums you would get a $2,500 tax
credit because this is a tax credit and
not a deduction it would be available to
everyone not just high income households
but that also means it would be more
expensive secondly Clinton would reduce
the marketplace premium Maxim
I know this is a little confusing
healthcare policy makes tax policy look
like a pleasant walk in the park but
basically right now the cost of health
insurance premiums on the marketplace
exchanges is effectively capped at nine
point six percent of income to not
benefit from the cap a family of four
has to make ninety six thousand dollars
a year or more basically Clinton's plan
would lower the cap from nine point six
percent to eight point five percent for
most households but of course that
program would also cost money and then
lastly and maybe most interestingly
Clinton would offer a public insurance
option on the exchanges this would allow
anyone not just seniors and low-income
people to get their insurance from the
government Rand hasn't yet updated its
analysis of the public option but
basically it would probably be cheaper
than private insurance because it would
share administrative costs with Medicare
and so it would slightly reduce the
deficit by reducing health care
subsidies so all in all according to
Rand I'm just going to quote again all
of the policies considered increase the
number of insured people and reduce
consumers out-of-pocket spending on
health care Rand estimates that the
Clinton tax credit alone would lead to
nine point six million more people
getting health insurance and that
households of all income levels would
see their out-of-pocket health care
expenses go down the biggest reduction
in health care costs would be for
families making between thirty and sixty
thousand dollars a year but they would
go down for every one but of course
these programs would also increase the
federal deficit by what Rand estimates
to be ninety billion dollars so that is
Rand summary Trump's plan would lead to
significantly higher out-of-pocket costs
fewer insured people and a modestly
higher budget deficit Clinton's plan
would insure more people lower
out-of-pocket costs but raise the
deficit more but of course you have to
consider those deficits in the broader
context of the candidates budget and tax
proposals and to be clear overall under
Trump's proposals the budget deficit
would be trillions of dollars more than
under Clinton's proposals the other
question of course is will either of
these proposals significantly reduce the
overall cost of US health care and the
answer is probably not the Trump
campaign will argue that selling
policies across state lines will
increase competition but that is deeply
contested and also even in the rosiest
projections it wouldn't decrease
spending much the Clinton campaign
meanwhile will say that a public option
would put real price pressure on private
insurers and it might but I'll put a
link in the dooblydoo explaining why a
single-payer health care system would
not magically fix the u.s. is problems
the truth is this is a complicated
multifaceted problem and anyone trying
to sell you some
both solutions probably isn't telling
you the whole story and that includes me
by the way this is definitely only an
introduction if you want to learn much
more about health care policy and health
insurance and different strategies for
dealing with it check out healthcare
triage they've got a great video out now
about medicaid's return on investment
and next week they'll have a much more
comprehensive analysis of the candidates
health care plans so subscribe to them
you can find sources as well as
information about how to vote in the
doobly-doo below Hank I will see you on
Friday unless you have a child in the
interim and screen Hank always says I
need an end screen so I put some videos
here about health insurance why you need
it what the health care system in the
United States is like why it's so
incredibly complicated also if you're
looking for a hot slice of tax policy
that video is just one click away and
rosianna drew you a bunny to cheer you
up
thanks Rosie Anna